okay so I have a microphone whooped
and you guys are seeing what I'm saying
as well okay so hey everyone hope you're
having a good day so far uh so welcome
to this talk about actor-based
development with project Orleans
so my name is Chris klug I work as a
software developer slash architect slash
public speaker slash I'm a consultant
right so I do what I get paid for I
think that's the way it works and mostly
within the tech industry
and uh a while back I had a client that
needed something a little bit different
and I started looking at Orleans
and Orleans if you look at it has a
definition Orleans is a cross-platform
framework for building robust scalable
distributed applications apps that span
more than a single process often Beyond
Hardware boundaries using peer-to-peer
communication
that is a lot of fancy words that says
very little to be perfectly honest so I
think we should go in and have a look at
what it actually does
but before we get started the funny
thing is that when I tell people that
I'm not so much anymore but about six
months ago when I told anybody at the
conference or any of the speakers that
when they come up and say so Chris what
are you talking about I'm going to talk
about project or lanes and they're all
like what
is that still a thing does anybody care
um
and there's a reason for that
so project Orleans has been around for
ages so producer Lanes was actually
designed and built and put into
production in 2011. so it's been around
for ages and it's been powering things
like Halo and Skype and a few other big
things so it's being used by Microsoft
and externally by large projects that do
need this hyperscale kind of thing and
it was open source in 2015.
still if you start talking about
projector Lanes some people have heard
about it and almost no one has ever
played with it or tried it out
and part of the reason for that is that
it is something that came out of
Microsoft's research and was brought in
to Halo as an internal thing and then
was open sourced and all the
documentation that was there previously
was very academic it was about
algorithms and things that was being
done inside of orlanes and very little
about how to get started and actually
using the product
of the latest version version 7 so they
jump from version three to seven because
versioning is hard apparently normally
it's one two three four but inversioning
is one two three seven
and they actually focused on making it
usable
so that is what we're going to look at
today
but I guess the question first is what
is the actor model and what is an actor
so basically an actor is a thing it's a
piece of code that basically runs in
memory somewhere that can perform
actions in half state
and in the actor model everything can be
an actor so anything you can think of
can be modeled as an actor as something
that's available in on your server so it
could be your shopping cart a shopping
cart could be an actor a user in the
multiplayer game could be an actor an
actual game as part of a multiplayer
game could be an actor
um I used it to model some stuff in an
online auctioning system where each
auction becomes its own actor because it
just made sense to have it architected
like that so everything can be an actor
however
Orleans isn't a pure actor model it is
what they call a virtual actor model
so what's the difference between an
actor model and a virtual actor model
not a whole lot the main thing is
when you ask for an actor in the virtual
actor model it gets created for you or
rehydrated or you get the thing that's
in in memory depending on the situation
so if you're asking for a new actor that
isn't available in memory or
instantiated it instantiates it for you
automatically if it's already in memory
it gives you a reference to that thing
and if it's something that has been in
memory but been garbage collected it
automatically just rehydrates it back up
and gives you a reference to that you
don't have to care about creating actors
and things like that it's just you ask
for an actor and there it is that is
apparently the big difference with a
virtual actor model
an actor is defined like this and I kind
of like it so an actor is an address
some behavior and potentially some
states
and that's
kind of simple
and it's kind of so it's an addressable
stateful service that can be easily
created and called
okay
once again lots of fancy words doesn't
say that much
but I actually like to look at it as a
distributed Isa container with named
Singleton instances
I also love the fact that I can add a
Microsoft conference now say a
distributed iuc container with Singleton
instances when all of you understand it
most of you at least if I had done that
at the.net conference 10 years ago
people would have looked at me and got
are you seek container what's that
what's a Singleton what the now we all
get that because we have a are you see
in dependence injection built into a
split core for example
so if you think of an Isa container that
we have today it looks like this right
you have your application it has an IEC
container it runs on one host in your
web app and you can ask for services
inside of that right and they can be
registered as Singleton or transient or
scoped or whatever you want but
basically if you go single turn you get
the same instance every time and it's
available and it's an easy way for you
to store State between different calls
into your web server for example
the current implementation of the ISE
container in aspenet is or in.net core
is that you end up with this so when you
scale out in a farm you end up with
multiple ioc containers right so you
have multiple instances because they're
all part of each of the apps and when
you scale out you get as many ioc
containers as you guess apps
which causes some problems because how
many of you have tried doing cash
invalidation in a server form
and enjoyed it
there's like one hand coming up and they
go nope did not enjoy caching is hard
right cash invalidation and handling
things and state is complicated and this
simplifies retrieving it but it doesn't
simplify the state management and the
cache eviction but if you were able to
do this
it would be a lot easier right so that
is what Orleans does for you it
basically gives you one ioc container
one container for all your services that
is spread across all of your machines in
your cluster you just ask for a service
and you don't have to care whether or
not it's on host a or host B it just
magically works and you get an interface
back and you can make calls to it
whether or not it's on your server or on
another server that is completely
transparent to you
oh yeah and it's single threaded by
default
it's because something like that that
would be spread out in a server form
that was multi-threaded and all of that
is really really complicated and it's
just I'm not smart enough to do
multi-threaded Computing it's just way
above my pay grade
this is single single threaded by
default so you don't have to care about
multi-threading and things like that
every call to your your actor is going
to be in sequence sequential which makes
it a lot easier to work with you can get
away from it though
so you can go multi-threaded if you're
really really smart
or think you are really really smart
but before we go any further we have to
talk about Orleans lingo so Orleans for
obvious reasons coming out of Microsoft
no bashing Microsoft sorry about that
I'm a Microsoft MVP I'm not supposed to
be bashing them but they obviously
renamed everything
because we had things like actor
um and we had things like nodes and
clusters and things but in Orleans they
decided to name a node a silo
and they decided to name an actor a
grain and you see where this is going
right
you have grains inside of silos inside
of your server Farm
yes it is that bad
it is really that bad but it you get
used to it it's called grains that's
just the way it is and they also so it
changes a bit also because you don't
have an address because you don't need a
full address to reach your your actor
because it's inside of Orleans so you
only need identity you don't need a full
address
so that that little thing I had before
changes a little bit with Orleans you
get a grain equals identity behavior and
then potential States
so all I need to know is that in this
case I'm looking for a user
um grain or actor
with the ID stereo call so the identity
becomes a combination of the type and
the the name that you've given it in
this case I'm using a string as an
identity but you can also do integers
and grids and combinations of those
then you have your behavior which is
basically your c-sharp class so it's a
it's a standard C sharp Poco that
inherits from grain and implements your
in your interface that you have defined
for your actor and then potentially
State well that is whatever you put into
memory so any form of variables that you
have inside your class is your state
but as I mentioned you have that virtual
actor thing so get versus create how do
I know if I need to create an accurate
if I can just retrieve it and with
Orleans you don't have to care so the
general idea is that when you call the
grain Factory and say can you please
give me a grain of type I user call zero
call
it's going to ask one Silo somewhere in
the cluster for that user or that grain
and that great Silo is then going to go
away and talk to the other silos and
figure out is there anybody in here that
actually has that grain in memory
already if there isn't then it's going
to go ahead and create that grain
somewhere in the cluster on one of the
nodes sorry on one of the silos
and then return a reference to to that
that grain
and
if I want to get that again and it's
already in memory then it's very simple
because it just runs off gets the thing
that's in memory gives me a proxy for
that and I'm good to go
but the cool thing about this model here
where it automatically just generates
actors for you on the Fly is that if
this Silo goes down
we have no changes to our code we don't
need to they don't need to handle it any
any way specifically because it was in
memory at one point if the node goes
down the request just comes in again it
goes ahead and checks the silos that are
left if none of them have an instance of
it it creates an instance and returns
and reference to that instance or a
proxy to it and we're good to go so it's
very very easy to work with
so I thought we'd go ahead and write a
little piece of code here just gonna see
if I can log into this so I can see so
I'm going to jump out of this and we're
going to pull up
you're not saying that are you
that that's kind of sucked let's see if
we can get this to be duplicate so you
can see my screen
now you can see it so I have this
project here I'm sorry if a little bit
small the code is going to be bigger but
I have a silo project a grains project
and a simulator project
so and if we look at the the projects
here the grains project that's going to
contain all of my grains or my actors it
only needs to reference the SDK
so you just add a simple nuget reference
to Microsoft Orleans SDK and you're good
to go I also have Microsoft Orleans
runtime because I'm doing some
persistence demos so I need another
nuget package as well but that's the
only thing you need in your grain
project
in the server side part of it which is
the silo
I add a reference to um
Microsoft Orleans server it's the only
thing you need
and now you're going to go but Chris you
have other nuget packages yes I do I
have the Orleans dashboard because I'm
going to show you that that's an
extension and then I have some other
stuff around here that has to do with
persistence that has to do with Orleans
doesn't isn't necessarily something you
need and then I have a couple of Hosting
things here to be able to host my silo
but everything that is or lanes and
makes me build a silo is in that one
nougat package and for the client which
is in this case going to be my simulator
project it also has a reference to a
Microsoft or Lanes package but it has
the Microsoft Orleans client that's it
so it's very simple there's a client
there's an SDK for the grains project a
server package for the server side or
the Silo and if you want to have a
client you have a Orleans client package
for that as well
and then inside of here I'm going to go
into my my grains project and I'm going
to go into the track location tracking
grains
and I'm going to first off start off by
nope
introducing the interface that I need to
create for my grain so I'm going to have
an eye location tracking grain so the
demo here is based on the idea that I
need to track something moving around
it happens to be me running around in
Stockholm because I got the GPX GPS
coordinates from my watch that was the
easiest thing to simulate so it
simulates location tracking and to be
able to track that I basically just need
a method called update location that
keeps track of
each user or each grain has state of
where where it's located at the moment
then it also needs to extend I grain
with string key so that interface
basically just tells Orleans that
there's going to be
this is going to be a grain it's going
to have a string key and the funny thing
is if you go in and have a look at this
it doesn't actually include anything
there's nothing on that there's nothing
on this
there's nothing on this I think
so it's totally empty interfaces and the
reason for that is that when you build a
an Orleans project there's actually a
source generators that generates a bunch
of code that gets injected into your
your grains just because you are
implementing that interface so it's kind
of a marker interface for functionality
uh one thing to note is that it takes so
first of all it's async it has to be
async because we don't know if it's
going to be in memory or it's going to
be a cross Network call
but anything that needs to be passed in
in the form of an object anything that's
a complex type has to be be marked with
generate serializer it is not the same
attribute as serializable that we are
used to using in in.net this is a
separate one and it requires you to put
IDs on each one of your properties to
get them in the right order when they
serialize and it has to do with using a
very efficient serialization algorithm
so that's why you need to dial that
manually
now it actually implementation of my my
brain
is this so it's pure C sharp nothing
complicated I inherit from grain which
is just a helper class
I Define the interface or implement the
interface that I'm I want to implement
which is simply the update location
and all I'm going to do in this grain is
I'm going to do console right line I'm
not doing anything here so whenever a
grain is created in the Constructor I do
a creating location tracking grain
console log and then for each update
locate location update I do another
console right line telling it what grain
is getting updated when it was updated
and the new latitude longitude
very very basic grain
so now that I have a grain that I can
work with
I can go to my silo
so this is the bare minimum Silo that
you can build it's a console application
it has a host in here because it's built
on top of I host in.net core so all I
need is an host add or lanes and then
start a sync and then wait for it to
stop that's the bare minimum of a silo
host that I can but being that it's
implemented as I host I could put it
into my aspnet core application right
because asp.net core has a host as well
or I could put it into anything that has
a host I can add a links to it
so all I need is to go in here and I
need to add our limbs now luckily adding
or Lanes is ridiculously easy
use or Lanes
that's it and then we have to pass in a
callback which is going to be a context
and the silo
like that
and then we have to tell The Silo what
kind of networking we want or what setup
we want we clustering for this I'm going
to go ahead and say use development
clustering so development clustering is
for actually that's not what I want this
time sorry
I don't want development just yet I want
localhost clustering sorry so this is
for development on your local machine it
sets up a one single node cluster for
your localhost using
127001 as the the IP address
and then I'm just going to go ahead and
say Silo dot use dashboard as well which
is that X extra nuget package that I
pulled in that gives us a little
dashboard that we can look at
that's it Silo done
client-side client-side I've built a
little project here that was not all
what I wanted to press I want to open
this
so I have once again is a little console
app
it creates a host it starts the host and
then basically it generates 10
simulators and the only thing that the
simulators do is that they basically
once every second they give another GPS
coordinate so we can see something
moving around on the map later on but
that's
updating the uh a grain basically
so to add the client part for this
application to be able to communicate
with my cluster once again we do use or
Lanes but in this case we do use Orleans
client
it has a callback
that looks like that
and we just say client dot use localhost
clustering like that and we're good to
go with the client nothing else that
needs to be configured it just
automatically works
now I need to get a hold of my a way to
access my cluster
and what we do is in here we say VAR
Cloud cluster client equals and then we
say host dot Services dot get required
class that's the one that we want
so we ask the host so when we call use
Orleans client is going to add something
called the icluster client to our ISE
container which allows us to talk to the
cluster
and then inside hire for each one of my
grains or sorry each one of my
simulators I'm going to go ahead and
pull out the grain so I'm going to say
vargrain equals clusterclient dot
getgrain of type I location tracking
grain like that and I'm going to give it
name so I'm just going to do name
because the strings the name is going to
be simulator one two three and so on and
then every time it needs to send a new
update to the grain all I need to do in
here is say await
grain dot update location once again you
can see in here once again but now you
can see here that on my interface here I
location tracking grain it just looks
like any other interface that you have
it has a few little helper things that
has to do with your lanes with getting
client IDs and things or clients IDs
primary Keys sorry and such but I also
got update location so I just use it
like any other C sharp class
I need to show in point unfortunate
point is in the wrong format so it has a
two location extension method to make it
into a location class
and that's it I have now created a grain
that has my state I've created a silo to
host it and I created a client that can
can call that that Silo so if we go
ahead and start up a silo
and obviously using localhost clustering
I can only use one Silo on my machine
because it uses
127001 and a predefined port and I can't
move it around
but at least it works
I'm just going to allow it to access
stuff
and then I can start my simulator
like that and if we pull up the so
there's my simulator and you start
simulating GPS positions and as you can
see here my Silo is getting updates so
it's each one of those console right
line gets output out here and if you
scroll up a little bit you can also see
up here that it's creating all of the
the grains for me based on simulator 8 2
6 5 and so on and it just runs and
there's no code in here that I have to
take care of to manage the fact that
it's a cross Network call or anything
like that it just works I just call my
interface and everything seems to work
so I'm going to try to stop that
gracefully ah no
keep forgetting this sorry let's let's I
was supposed to show you one more thing
and I keep closing that too early every
time let's do debug
new instance
start the simulator I wanted to show you
this first so I added the dashboard
and the reason I added that is that it's
really nice to be able to see this so
just because I use the added use Orleans
dashboard I actually get a built-in
dashboard so The Silo automatically
gives me a dashboard that I can just
browse to and get information about my
grain so I can go in here and I can see
what grains are being created here there
are 10 activations on my location
tracking grain I can see throughput and
all of that stuff and that was just that
one line of use dashboard to be able to
get to work
that I kind of like that it gives us a
nice way of just quickly getting an
overview of what's actually going on in
there
so grain creation and setting up your
first initial grain application or a
Orleans application isn't really that
hard
but there's more to it right there
obviously something that has to do with
silos and communication and clustering
and we all know that clustering things
and building web servers in forms and
stuff is complicated right
so Microsoft has tried to take that away
as much as possible from Orleans so
they only have two ports that your
stylus need to be able to communicate on
so as long as you have your silos on the
network where they can reach each other
and they can use two ports that you can
Define on your own you're good to go
that's all that you need to set it up
and by default you use thirty thousand
to communicate with the silo from the
outside so with if you have a client and
then it uses 11 11 to have a gossip
protocol between all the the silos
inside of your cluster
so it's fairly simple to set up
and as I showed you
localhost clustering very very simple
runs on your local machine setting it up
is this use localhost clustering for The
Silo and use localhost clustering for
the client that's it
if you want to go a bit further you can
do development clustering
this is by nature not for production it
is called development clustering do not
go and use this for production because
what you do is you basically say
I have a bunch of silos but one Silo is
the master and if that Silo goes down
your entire cluster goes down pretty
shitty version of a clustering situation
right but that's the way that the
development clustering works so you
basically set up all as many stylists as
you want but you make one the master and
that's the one that keeps track of all
the other silos and all you need to do
is basically tell each one of the silos
which where can you reach the main or
the master Silo that has all of The Silo
information
and on the client you then tell it that
hey I want to use static clustering and
here is the address where you can reach
the the master node or one of the nodes
in the cluster but preferably with the
masternode because that's always going
to be up and you're good to go and then
you can host as many silos as you want
on your local machine if you want to
but a much better solution is using
something called a clustering provider
and I really love this feature because
all you do is just you go in and you
choose a provider and that can be in
this case I'm using Azure so I'm using
Azure storage clustering which is
basically telling each of my silos that
hey you're part of a cluster and all of
the clustering information should be
over here in table storage and then I'm
good to go I don't have to do anything
else if a cluster goes offline or a silo
goes offline the rest of the silos
handles that if that new Silo comes
online it communicates with all of the
others so you can add and remove silos
as you want and they use table storage
in this case to keep track of it and to
configure it all you need to do is give
it a connection string to table storage
and it does everything else on its own
and for the client it is the same thing
as you can see there's no difference
except for use or Lanes versus your use
Orleans client other than that it's
exactly the same Community configuration
you can also do ado.net so if you want
to back your uh your cluster by using
SQL for example you can just give it a
connection string to a SQL database and
it will store all of the clustering
information in the SQL
and once again they look pretty much
identical whether or not this is a silo
or a client
and if we have a look at what that looks
like I'm going to go ahead and I'm going
to do some Silo changes or clustering
changes on my mesh application here so
I'm going to go out I'm going to kill
that first of all
so I'm going to start in The Silo which
is here
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to remove my these things here
because I'm I'm done with that so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to say Silo
dot use development clustering to start
off
like that
and that thing is going to ask me for an
IP endpoint so I'm going to go a new IP
endpoint like that
I'm going to give it IP address Dot
loopback
and I'm going to give it Port 1 11 000.
loopback 11 11.
so that is not configuring this Silo
this is configuring where the master
Silo is located
so for my own Silo for this local one
I'm also going to go and say Hey I want
to configure the endpoints in here
so I'm going to change the endpoints a
bit and then I can go and say okay so
I'm going to have an IP address loop
back for this thing
normally you shouldn't have to input and
tell it specifically to use the loopback
adapter but due to my machine having a
Docker and desktop installed it actually
defaults not to 127001 it defaults to
one seven two zero zero something that
has to do with Docker so I have to tell
it what IP address to to use for this
local local silo
hey I want you to communicate on Port
111 and Port 30 000.
now the
estate person in the cloud in in the
crowd now is going to look at this and
go
but if you pull up more than one of
these silos aren't they going to collide
on Port 111 and put thirty thousand yes
they are so that's not going to work I
have an ugly workaround for this this is
not for any kind of production use it is
for demo purpose on my machine locally
right now but I'm gonna write this
so I'm going to go process get process
get as how many location dot
tracking.silo processes are on my
machine at the moment
for the first Silo that is going to be
one for the rest of them it's going to
be two three four and so on and if the
silo count is one then I'm going to set
my port spread to zero otherwise I'm
going to do a random number between 0
and 1000 and then I'm just going to go
ahead and add that down here
which basically means that each one of
these
uh the consecutive asylus that I pull up
are going to end up on individual IPM
ports so they don't Collide on my local
machine this is only because I'm running
multiple ones on my my local machine
and then for uh for the uh
client sorry that was wrong one that's
the one and for the client part of it
I'm gonna have to go in and make a
little change here as well so I'm not
going to go to localhost clustering I'm
going to do client dot use the static
that's what I want to study clustering
like that and what I need to go in here
is the same thing I have to tell it
oh
tell it's new IP endpoint like that and
it's going to be IP address Dot loopback
and it's going to communicate on Port 30
000 with that Silo as such
now that's all the change I need to
actually change the whole clustering
model for my application so if I go and
I add debug here so I go and create one
silo
I'm gonna place this Silo up in the top
left corner because it's the most
important Silo remember to not delete
that
then I'm going to go and create another
silo
so D sorry debug new instance
it's another Silo nope nope
and I'm going to go ahead and start a
third Silo in here
and then finally I'm going to go and
create a simulator that starts sending
out messages
and what you're gonna see hopefully is
that
they are sort of hopefully somewhat
evenly distributed across my silos like
that
so you can see some information is
ending up on the different silos and if
I go ahead and kill one of these silos
not the master one any of the other ones
that is going to slowly die
that sounds bad but that's kind of what
I'm doing I'm slowly killing it and once
that is dead you can see out here
there's a bunch of stuff that says that
one of the silos went down it stopped
working
and I stopped the wrong window didn't I
damn it I there are two windows I can't
stop there's a 50 shot the chance that
I'm stopping the wrong one that was the
wrong one that was apparently the client
so let's try this again
uh
uh okay and now it breaks on top sorry
if you close down the right Silo it will
reschedule that load on the other other
silos as soon as the request comes in as
I showed you in the PowerPoint
presentation before it's just a matter
of remembering to close the right
console on this machine
now a much easier and nicer way of doing
this is to use storage clustering
so if we go to The Silo again and we
remove the development clustering in
here and we go and we do
that so basically I'm doing use Azure
storage clustering instead I go and
configure table service client and all I
do is I give it a connection string
which I've put into an environment
variable on my machine and I use the
same port spread configuration thing
here
and then I go back to my my client and
do the same thing I basically kill that
and we do 0.5 like that and I do the
same thing use Azure storage clustering
and I give it a a connection string if I
now run my silos again
I don't have to care at all I don't have
I can pull down silos in whatever order
I want and they will just keep on
working and in table storage there will
be a complete list of silos that are up
and running at the moment so if I start
three of those and I start my
my simulator
that's my simulator that is not going to
get killed let's put that on the side
like that
and then I have three silos here
somewhat evenly distributed let's take
that one and kill that one
and that goes down
and the other ones take over
so that load is now being distributed on
that if I go in here and I go and start
another Silo in here that Silo is going
to be really really boring and do
nothing
because there's no load to put on it yet
so it doesn't redistribute any load just
because I pull up a new xyler because
everything is still instantiated on the
old silos but if I go in I kill off that
Silo hopefully some of that should end
up on this Silo instead
maybe there is
some of it ends up on this island so you
can just pull down silos and add silos
and remove silos in whatever order we
want and they just kind of make it work
and store everything in table storage
now there's a cameraman right in front
of me and I always look like a complete
on those pictures I'm gonna have
like a weird thing like that so and
that's when he took the picture yeah
um okay
anyway Silo clustering fairly easy to
work with
um observing grains is another really
cool feature uh that I kind of like
so what we got is something called an i
Observer and it allows a grain to push
information out from the grain so that I
can observe it which allows me to
basically monitor grains in my
application in a nice way and after that
one slide I'm gonna go and go into the
demo again it's useful slide probably
skip that one so what I'm going to do
here is I have
to slide this up here
I wanna I wanna keep track of the
locations of my different grains so that
I can show that off
and I have a little application API up
here that were sorry a dashboard that
I'm going to show you that's going to do
that tracking but
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
first off sorry I'm gonna remember to do
this I'm going to revert back to low
close clustering because that's
simple and nice very few things that can
go wrong with that I'm going to change
that in my simulator as well
I'm gonna add that
and remove that like that okay so
what I'm going to do is I I you You
observe one grain at a time so I don't
want to have to go and set up 50
different observables for each one of
the grains that is running in my
application instead I'm going to combine
the list of latest updates into its own
grain so I'm going to go and add a new
class in here
I'm going to call it dashboard grain
like that
and then I'm going to implement that so
it looks like this
so it's going to be an eye dashboard
grain it's going to be a grain with a
good key it's going to have a add
position update so each one of the the
location tracking grains can go and say
here is my latest grain and their latest
position so they're all going to feed
into this one grain that keeps track of
all the other grains where there are so
I can get a list of the current
positions and then I'm going to have a
what's called an eye dashboard Observer
which is an eye grain Observer
and that's where I can go and say I want
to subscribe to changes inside this
grain and I do that by implementing I
dashboard Observer and I have on that
interface I have an on position updated
where I can get like a list of positions
that I can get out so whenever it the
position list changes I can get updated
with that
now
nope
actually I want to have that was the
wrong one no it was seven there it is so
here's the implementation now a little
tiny tweak here is that the interface is
called I dashboard grain I actually call
my class location dashboard grain and
the reason for that is that your grains
are not allowed the class implementation
are not allowed to be the same name as
any other class that is a grain in your
system and if I use the the dashboard
for um Orleans that has a grain called
dashboard grain so if you end up having
a class with the same name it's going to
collide and say that there's already an
implementation of that because it
doesn't take namespaces into account
this can be modified but by default if
you have unique class names it makes a
lot easier which is why I'm naming it
location dashboard grain
it implements I dashboard grain
it basically just has a list of current
positions
and whenever it starts up I go and
create a little log here then I create a
timer so register timer is a helper
class from the grain class that I
inherit from that allows us to have
timers coming back on the same thread
that everything else is so we keep that
single threaded Thing by using a timer
like this instead of setting up like a
system dot
threading.timer or wherever they're
located
there's also something called a reminder
reminders are a little bit different
timers can run on a fairly rapid Cadence
and they're basically only as long as
your grain is in memory but if you put
up a reminder a reminder has must have a
slower Cadence but you can actually
start up your grain when it needs run so
it's persisted even if your grain gets
removed the reminder will basically pull
your grain back into memory and execute
the reminder if it isn't in memory
already
but I'm going to go with a timer I'm
going to call send updates and I'm going
to do that every second so once a second
I'm going to send out updates to tell me
where everything is
then for add position updated
well it's a sharp it's not very
important or interesting it's basically
current position contains client k then
add it otherwise add it like that
subscribe well that's also kind of the
same thing it's just
add it to the list of observers so I
have an a hash set of I dashboard
Observer I just store it in there
unsubscribe while not completely
surprising it removes it from that list
of subscribers once again pure C sharp
nothing complicated at all
and then for send updates we basically
go ahead and we say
that so I do console right lines sending
updates and then I do a little select
thing to get the format of my positions
out to client ID and location
and then I just go through each one of
The Observers calling on positions
updated passing back that that positions
object
once again I don't have to care about it
going over the wire or anything like
that it just magically works
and also this by the way is not async
there is no it doesn't tell you or it
doesn't have any proof that it will have
delivered the message the message is
fire and forget and it might not arrive
at the the end point that it's supposed
to be that's something to keep in mind
but in some cases that is okay like in
this case
and then I just return complete the task
so and once again the the implementation
is just Simple Pure C sharp the fact
that it's over the wire has no impact
whatsoever on the code that I'm writing
and then I'm gonna go ahead to my go to
my location tracking grain because this
grain here is going to go ahead and tell
that other grain that hey I got an
update so I keep the the central
repository updated continuously so what
I'm going to do is inside my Constructor
here I'm going to ask for an eye grain
Factory
like that
let's store that
so because migraines are registered in
the ioc container together with our
lanes my grains are allowed to get
injected any services that are
registered in that ioc container
including the ones that are being added
by Orleans themselves so I can go ahead
and say hey can you please give me the
grain Factory that is used to access
grains inside this silo
so I'm just going to get that injected
and once I have that I can go down to my
update location stuff here and we're
going to replace this
with something that looks like this
so I'm still
nope
with something that looks like
this so I still do a right line in here
to write out the thing but I'm also
calling grain Factory get gray and here
is a little tweak
if you pass in a grid dot empty it's
always going to be the same which means
that I'm actually asking for a Singleton
grain so I'm always going to get the
same grain no matter of what grain I'm
I'm asked requesting it from grid.mt is
going to be unique and it's going to be
the same thing every time
and then I call add position updated to
basically tell it that hey this grain
here has a new location and that gets
stored in the the
dashboard grain
so now that I have that in place we
should be able to go and start listening
to this and to do that please don't
laugh but I have built a WPF application
you laughed I just I just said please
don't laugh
WPF is fantastic but I also built it
using like the latest and the greatest
so it built on.net core with winxy and
things like that or use Net 7 Windows
and then I took a dependency on
um
a mapping service
I took a dependency on Bing Maps
which isn't actually available though
that course I get a yellow warnings
thing and it doesn't really work as it
should but it doesn't matter it's a WPF
application and it runs even though
there's a warning symbol
so what I'm going to do in here inside
my main window here
I do a few little things so I need an
eye host so inside my main window what I
do in the on initialize is that I go and
create a new host like that and I add an
Orleans client to it so that I can use
Orleans
and then I do some stuff here about
onstart async and continue with blah
blah blah on closing uh the important
part is that when it has started up and
the window is in view it calls on host
started and when it is closing down it
calls on host stopping so this is where
I need to do stuff and then there's a
method here called update positions
which is responsible for moving the pins
around on the actual map as such fairly
uninteresting for the demo as such
but we want to go ahead and change
let's see I'm going to start out with
this one
nope
nope sorry that I need that first
it even says add backwards or first we
need this let's start with this one
so I'm creating a class here called
dashboard of server that implements I
dashboard Observer and it basically is
just a call through so whenever uh
on positions updated is being called it
calls this callback function this action
which I'm gonna set up so that it does
some stuff for me
now I have my little implementation of
that now I can go ahead and I can go up
here and we can say
no there is so now
I'm going to add a couple of these
so what is happening in here well first
of all I I asked my host for the
icluster client service so I can talk to
my cluster then I ask my cluster client
service to give me an act give me an a
proxy to the I dashboard grain with good
empty
then here is the funky part then I go
and create a new instance of dashboard
Observer which is my implementation of I
dashboard Observer
and then I send that to Cluster client
create object reference of I dashboard
of the server and get back another thing
which by definition is also an i
dashboard Observer
I pass that version to the dashboard
grains subscribe method
now I want to point out that this looks
weird and it is weird but what is
happening is that we create an instance
on something and then we ask the cluster
client to create a proxied version of
that thing that can be passed off to the
The Silo so that it can get requests
coming back
now I started out by doing this code
like this
and then I ran this code and it worked
perfectly for about 15 seconds and then
it stopped working completely
then I closed down my application I
started it again it worked perfectly for
about 12 seconds and then it stopped
working and that was kind of repetitive
and as a developer I kind of realized
that I'm probably doing something wrong
so this Observer ref in here
is only has a weak reference to the
actual implementation so if we remove
this or sorry the this that one sorry if
we had that one if we let that go and we
don't keep that in memory that's going
to get garbage collected and when that
gets garbage collected this thing is
going to lose its reference and it's
going to stop working so just
if you're doing observables remember to
keep references to your um your
implementations of your eye the grain
Observers
passed it in like that fairly simple as
such once you figure that out it took a
while honestly it wasn't very well
documented and then in on stopping
we just go ahead and we we unsubscribe
our Observer ref so we don't
keep getting notifications when we're
done
and that's kind of kind of it so what's
going to happen now is that I'm going to
start a silo
gotta do nope not uh debug
do a debug on my silo
that's going to start up a silo we've
seen that before
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to start my simulator we've seen that
before as well
and if we look at these two we should be
getting updates now right yep so this
thing is getting updates so what is
happening now is that you also see
sending updates coming out here so it's
first of all all of the grains are are
telling the dashboard grain that here
are my latest updates and then the
dashboard grain every second is going to
send all of the current updates out to
whoever wants to listen to it
and the thing that is going to listen to
it is this dashboard thing here
and if I start that up
it's going to create that grain Observer
it's going to pass that along to my my
back end and all of a sudden I can
externally get updates on everything
that's going on in my cluster because I
have that observability between the
different grains as you can see the
little
little pins moving around that is the up
that's being moved around and I'm
observing it from the outside of the
cluster which can be really nice and you
can obviously observe not only from the
outside listening to grains inside your
cluster grains inside of your cluster
can listen to changes in grinds inside
of the cluster as well so you can have
these dependency between your grains so
that they can see what is happening
internally
that is pretty sweet I like it
somebody asked this I was running very
fast because if you look at the scale
I'm moving ridiculously fast I'm not a
fast runner but if you just tweak the
speed that you send the updates it goes
a lot faster
okay so observing grains is kind of a
neat feature as well
can be used for a lot of cool stuff
but one thing that that I got stuck with
that I really enjoyed was persistence
so grains will automatically get the
garbage collected right because they're
just part of.net so if they're not being
called continuously the garbage
collector is going to say hey you don't
need to be in memory anymore I'm going
to throw you out which is what we want
but we also want to be able to have
persistence we want to make sure that if
the garbage collector throws out one of
my actors and migraines I want to be
able to rehydrate that and have it back
to the state that I had before right
and there are ways to do that and
there's first of all there are built-in
persistence stuff so basically you have
these things here and they will persist
your state in some form of defined State
like ado.net Azure storage uh in memory
which is kind of weird uh dynamodb and
so on but what they do is they store
your state in Json inside of some
storage which means that it's kind of
you store stuff separately from your
rest of your application because it's
just put in here because I want to be
able to rehydrate it if you want to
integrate with your own storage
mechanism that is actually quite nice
there's something called eye grain
storage that allows you to basically
pull data into your grains from an
existing state storage so from existing
database and save it back down there as
well which means that I built a demo for
a client in about four hours to do an
auctioning system but I could leave all
of their database stuff and everything
could build the the auctioning stuff on
top of it but it would still read and
persist the data in to their database in
their format because I had implemented
one of these and all you need is
basically Implement three methods read
State clear clear State and write States
fairly simple
but you also need to put a persistent
State attribute on one of your
Constructor parameters and then you need
to accept a parameter in your
Constructor for your your grain that is
of type I persistent state of t
so what does that look like well it
looks like this
so in my grain it doesn't store the
grain as a whole it stores State objects
those State objects in this case being
passed in as I persistent state of my
state
that is what's going to get get
persisted and what I'm going to read
from so when this grain here gets
activated the eye persistent state of my
state is that state variable is going to
be pre-populated with the state that I
want in there and then I can call on
that I persistent state to persist
things as well so it doesn't persist the
grain it persists objects inside the
grain but the fact that it's an
attribute that your parameter to your
Constructor means that you can actually
get State injected from several
different things so you could have this
part of my state comes from blob storage
this part of my state comes from this
database this thing here comes from some
other place it's up to you to implement
it which means that you can have like a
combination of state from different
sources in the same grain
and it's actually not that hard to do
weirdly enough because the API is so
simple
so I'm going to go to
my dashboard grain so what I want to
build is basically I want to keep track
so if
if my update the The Silo goes down and
comes back up again I want or and my
simulators aren't working properly I
want to have the last state to the last
position known position for everything
to come back up when I start my
dashboard so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go in here
and I'm going to add an inner class in
this location draft down here let's just
there it is so I'm going to go ahead and
I'm going to add a
an inner class here called dashboard
States
and it's going to be just a dictionary
string location last known positions I'm
going to default it to a new new
dictionary that's it
and then
I'm going to add a new class in here
that's gone out here uh new class uh the
class
I'm gonna call it
dashboard
State Storage
think I spelled that properly
I'm going to implement that like this
so it's going to be really stupid State
Storage so it takes us path to store the
states and then clear State I don't care
because I don't ever clear the state in
this demo but I could have implemented
that read State and write State let's
start with right because it makes more
sense
all it really does it creates a last
known positions.json file and puts it in
the the path that I told it to and
serializes the uh the state into that
and for read state
I read that Json file as you can see it
can it basically says that hey you want
to read some states what's the type of
state that you want to read and then so
I can use the same implementation for
different state objects as such if I if
I want to do that but for this it's very
simple if you're looking for a location
dashboard grain dot dashboard State then
read the information from the last known
positions.json file
now
I'm gonna go to the silo
here
and inside here I'm going to go ahead
and I'm going to add
this so I'm going to add a named
Singleton service to my silos services
I'm going to have it's going to be an
eye grain storage implementation it's
going to be called dashboard State
storage and when it gets created when I
instantiate it it's going to go ahead
and create a new dashboard State Storage
pointing it to that location on my hard
drive
that's kind of it
and then once I got that registered I
can go to my dashboard grain no my yeah
actually my life will grain there it is
can go in here I'm gonna let's see if
I'm gonna replace this I am
so in my Constructor here I'm now asking
for a persistent state that is going to
be the dashboard State Storage type that
I just registered and it's going to have
an i persistent state of dashboard state
I can store that state
like that
and then we can go ahead and change this
implementation down here where it says
current positions
we're just going to return state DOT
state DOT last known positions like that
instead so we're reading it from the
state instead of our in-memory version
as such and then in my send updates
I'm going to go in here and we're gonna
change that to a weight
state DOT saves sorry write States async
like that and that's going to persist it
so every second is going to persist it
down so that if you kill it it's gonna
it's gonna work as it should
if I now go and create my silo
debug create Silo I just need to get it
sort of initialized to start off so I'm
going to start the silo I'm gonna run my
grains so I'm gonna run my simulator
now it's got some states so it should
have stored the last known position so
I'm going to stop that thing I'm going
to stop that thing so now that Json file
should be available on my drive
so if we kill this thing off
there it is we start The Silo again but
there are no simulators up and running
if we start that it should Now read up
that state so if I pull up my dashboard
and I run that
it should be able to find
the last known positions for the all the
simulators that was running when the
application died and there they are
so we got basically a way to persist and
restore State based on whatever state
store that we want this is a pretty
stupid demo but it kind of shows off the
idea that we can't have state and we can
store it in whatever way we want instead
of just having some form of generic Json
storage into blob storage for example
so I have some comments about it or like
thoughts after having worked with it so
first of all threading I did mention
that it's single threaded which makes a
lot of things a lot easier like I said
the auction system I worked on was
really nice because what they had
initially when we you're running an
auctions online auction system and you
get loads of bids coming in at once the
whole idea of having to go and lock a
row in the database and verify that the
bid is higher than the previous bid and
while that is being locked everyone else
has to wait and then if it is higher
than the last bit then it's going to go
down and update it and add a new bid and
so on and you have all these locking
things going on it gets complicated with
Orleans it was like I said I implemented
kind of what they had in four hours and
everything is single threaded so it
means that bids come in in the order
that they're sent basically and all you
have to do is check your in-memory list
of your bids and verify whether or not
it's higher or lower than the previous
bid and everything is in memory really
really fast so it was really nice and
offloaded the database a whole lot
however if you are smarter than me which
some of you probably are you can go and
add attributes to your uh your grains to
say that hey this should be a re-entrant
basically it should be multi-threaded or
you can add always interleave or may
interleave which basically allows other
grains to call back into yourself again
if you have a chain of grain calls back
and forth but you have to know what
you're doing when you're going
multi-threaded I'm just going to say
that
don't use icluster clients so Chris has
now done a one hour talk and demoed how
to use the icluster client to talk to
your cluster and then at the last slide
I'm going to say don't use the icluster
clients
the reason for this is that the
communication between an icluster client
and your cluster cannot be ensured to be
secure because it uses a bunch of really
cool networking stuff under the hood
which means that we don't want to have
somebody from the outside talking to the
cluster so if how do we do that in that
case well if we look at what I had going
on
I also have a little thing in here I
have an API
and this is basically what you should be
doing for this scenario instead is that
in your web API you add or Lanes to your
your asplate core application and you
configure it just as you would in my my
other Stylo solution
but then you expose a control locations
controller and then you let the the
simulator call the API instead so the
simulator shouldn't be talking to the
cluster straight away the simulator
should be talking to the API instead and
then the API can talk to the cluster in
a secure way because as the silos are
registered in this application I can use
the igrain factory which is local to me
and it doesn't use any network coming
into the cluster from the outside so
having your your cluster or an API in
front of your cluster and using the eye
grain factories a much much better
solution because it means that you can
have security from the client to the API
using SSL and logins and things like
that and then you can secure your
cluster internally on your network and
make sure that all communication between
the nodes are are safe in that way
because they are going to be quite
chatty and they are not going to be
securely chatting between them
so don't use the cluster client unless
you have a weird scenario like my WPF
application
other than that I've got two minutes
left I want to thank you all for
listening the code for what I demoed is
available on that address so if you want
to have a look at it feel free to browse
it feel feel free to ping me on on
Twitter if you have any questions and I
will be around here and then during the
day today at the conference if you have
any questions so just grab me in that
case
thank you so much
[Applause]